(upbeat music)
- Hello.
- I heard that y'all actually
just ran into each other.
- A few days ago.
- That's so funny.
- That's true, we did.
- Did you know you were both coming here?
- I did.
- [Kelly] You did?
- In fact, I think I mentioned it.
I was very excited about it.
- Yeah.
- No, I just thought it was funny
that you ran into each other,
and you're like, "I'll see you
in a few days." (chuckling)
- It's kind of like a campus,
it's getting smaller
and smaller and smaller.
- I like it.
- The more we go closer
to the day.
- Alright, I like your club.
Well, you were talking about your daughter
the last time that you were here.
Is she two now?
- She's two years old.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah, she's two years old.
- Is it terrible twos or fun?
Is it fun?
- Oh, I think it's inspirational twos.
(Kelly laughing)
I'm just like-
- That's a very good answer, PC.
- Thank you so much, yeah. (chuckling)
Highly trained.
- Yeah.
- Yeah,
that's what I'm known for.
(Kelly laughing)
Total control.
But yeah, she's really confident.
She climbs up everything.
- [Kelly] Sure.
- She was at a pool party this weekend,
and started chanting her own name
and made everyone else do it.
- [Brendon] What's her name?
- Love it.
- Her name is Ida.
- [Kelly And Brendon] Ida, Ida, Ida!
- I love that she's
like her own hype girl.
That's awesome.
- Yeah, I mean, I was like,
- It's cool.
"I wish I could be like that now."
(Kelly laughing)
Yeah, yeah.
- Wait, you were also raising
chickens the last time I saw.
How are the chickens?
- Okay, this is a weird thing to say,
but they were a rental.
- [Kelly] What?
- Yeah. They-
- What?
- Because when I got the
chickens, I was like,
I'll just be this kind
of person who's like,
"Hey, I'm earthy. I have chickens."
(Kelly laughing)
But really, my husband was like,
"You're not going to want
these chickens for very long."
And there was a guy near us,
we live in Massachusetts,
most of the year.
And he rents chickens.
Kind of like, why not?
Memorial Day to Labor Day.
And, yeah.
- [Kelly] That's interesting.
- We got rid of those girls.
They were really weird.
- Yeah, those hens were
hard to handle, okay.
- Those hens were following
my husband around everywhere
and I was like, I almost
got a little bit jealous.
(Kelly laughing)
Like they didn't want to
have anything to do with me
and they just followed my husband around.
And then-
- Did you like having eggs though?
That's kind of cool.
- Here's the thing.
- Oh!
- We were getting like
one egg every four days.
- What?
- They just were weird
and they slept on the top of their coup.
- Lazy chickens.
- Lazy, lazy chickens.
Pop them out, girls.
What the heck?
- I want some eggs.
- [Jenny] I want some eggs, yeah.
- You probably had no ticks
in the backyard, right?
- Oh, I wish. I mean, not to-
- Lazy chickens.
- I know, not to be a bummer, but yeah.
That's a got, a big tick
problem in Massachusetts.
- Well, the Northeast, yeah.
- [Kelly] In Texas as
well, where I'm from.
Yeah. Yeah.
Well, have you ever had any chickens?
I know everybody's like
checking themselves.
- Did you see, I just did that too.
- Everyone itches.
Have you ever had any
like, not odd animals,
but farm animals or anything like that?
Other than like a dog or cat?
- I've had a horse.
- [Kelly] Oh, okay.
- He was very important to me.
I met him making a film in Mexico.
We bonded.
I couldn't say goodbye,
so I had him sent up from Durango
to past Suarez to El Paso.
He got on a FedEx and he flew,
flew him to New York City.
- A horse flew FedEx.
- [Brendon] Yes. That's the
easiest way to get him there.
- They really will deliver everything.
- Correct.
- Yeah.
- They will.
And he was a great
companion to my oldest son
who has an intellectual disability.
He's autistic.
And so even if he didn't want a ride,
you could give him a brush and a bucket.
And you know, they're both happy,
all afternoon, you know?
- No, it's very therapeutic.
They do that all the time.
- Oh, ab-
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Equine therapy.
- Absolutely.
- Yeah. That's cool.
Well, congrats on the Oscar nomination.
- Oh, thank you.
- Yeah.
- I just was looking at him.
- Well, both of you are Oscar nominated.
It's awesome. You're both nominated.
So this is also for a
best animated feature.
So tell us about the movie and
how it felt to get nominated.
- Sure.
The movie is called "Marcel
the Shell with Shoes On."
It's about a one-eyed
shell who has two shoes.
There he is!
(Kelly laughing)
And it's directed by Dean Fleischer Camp.
And we wrote it together
with our friend, Nick Paley.
And it's about a little
guy who mysteriously,
sort of, at the start
of the film at least,
loses his family
and meets a documentarian
who starts to kind of,
chronicle his story and
then they get an opportunity
to perhaps find the family.
And it's about that
process of figuring out
if you even wanna go on an adventure
and I think it's very lovely,
- Yeah.
very close to the heart.
Yeah. And finding out that we
were nominated for an Oscar.
It was a,
a trip.
- Yeah. Like, wait, what?
- Yeah, it really was, I have
nothing to compare it to.
It was not even anything
I've ever dreamed of.
Like I just always really
wanted to be an actor.
That was like, that's
definitely good enough for me
to just be chosen to play
a role and have a camera.
You know, like, I just wanted that.
And it was probably like a
little past four in the morning
and I was getting all
these texts on my phone
and I knew it was Oscar
nomination day, and I was like,
I kind of think someone would've called.
You know, like I think these
might be apology texts.
- Like, "Oh, sorry, it didn't happen."
"Maybe next time."
- Totally, totally.
And then, and so I was like, meh,
I kind of rolled over in bed,
and then someone, my friend Liz,
who produced the film called and said
that we've been nominated for an Oscar.
- [Kelly] That's so cool.
- Yeah.
(audience cheering)
- That's so cool.
So you paid tribute to your grandmother's,
both of them, right?
Isn't it?
- Yes.
- I love that. Why was
this important to you?
- You know, my grandmothers
are just like the
some of the closest relationships
I've ever experienced.
- [Kelly] That's wonderful.
- Yeah. It's, it's lovely.
And my grandmother, Rochelle,
recently passed and-
- I'm sorry.
- [Jenny] Yeah, that was really hard.
And the grandmother in the
film is named Nana Connie,
that's my other grandmother's name.
The grandmother in the film
has a beautiful accent.
There she is.
- [Brendon] Aww.
- [Jenny] She's played
by Isabella Rossellini,
who has a, a gorgeous accent.
And my grandmother, Rochelle
was born in Havana, Cuba,
in 1930, and then moved to Paris in about,
I don't know, maybe 1933 or
34 and our family is Jewish.
They basically ran right
into Second World War.
She became, she was a Holocaust survivor.
- Wow.
- She had a gorgeous accent,
an incredible outlook on life.
And that all went into that character.
I think my father might have described her
as like an artist without a genre.
And just super dreamy.
- [Brendon] I love that.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Wow. Your family's magical.
- I think so.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah. That's nice.
Okay, well, we have a clip.
This is when Marcel is about to leave home
in search of his family
and he is getting his grandmother prepared
to live without him for a while.
- Alright!
So you've got the book, you've
got a little bit of a raisin,
which I really don't
think you're gonna finish,
but you can go to town.
Go to town.
Also, you have two drips
of wa- Look over here.
You have two drips of water.
You got an LED flashlight
in case the power goes out.
You just gotta step on it like this.
See? See how-
Whoa, sorry.
Don't stand right in front of it.
Finally, now, this is the sparkler.
What you do is you light this end on fire
and then you step back.
This can act as a flare, right?
- What would I need?
- That's if you need a signal for help
and Dean's going to leave
you his phone just in case.
- What? I don't know him.
- You know what?
Now that I'm thinking about it
why don't we just put the
colander over you now if you want.
- [Marcel] How's that?
- You must let me out of here.
- Just let me out of here.
(crowd applaud)
So, "Marcel the Shell with
Shoes On" is nominated
for an Oscar for best animated feature.
You can stream it now on demand.